hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today Raul is joining
me because we are going to play the
first hour
of Warhammer bolt gun
Warhammer 40K yeah yeah uh because Rahul
voice is this guy what's his name malam
kaido yeah
uh if the storm Gods Ultra respect nice
one banjo
um I have not played it intentionally
even though you've been playing at a
bunch of and avoiding it so I'm gonna go
even a medium okay
charge launched forward towards enemy
shoving them and dealing damage okay
um and I've been really excited about
this regardless of rahul's involvement
in fact we saw the trailer before you
became part of the game and both really
liked it because it looks a lot like
Doom nothing
Nothing by the hand of chaos remains um
which if you've seen any of the trailers
or anything it's very much
Doom inspired
she's already had more lines than me we
haven't said anything have you Village
World remains largely secure but we have
picked up concerning energy readings in
the surrounding system
I have my suspicions although we have
not had sufficient time to pinpoint it's
pretty so that sounds very nice
remains unaffected it is my belief sorry
if you can hear the dog
your mission is to assist me in the
painting of fragments okay I got you
that could be you and you're older
absolutely
yeah I feel like every woman in the
world in the universe has white hair
they probably will it's going to develop
into a more dire situation
here is one of his one abused and divine
numbers
you can see where everyone
communication has become sporadic cool
should you encounter any opposition
I didn't expect it to have this much
story
well it's yeah I know it's just setting
up like where I'm going but
you're basically going back to before
12.
wait does it like overlap with others
yeah that's cool I didn't know that so
Space Marine with Captain Titus
this is the
that's cool oh all right okay okay King
oh no
Mountain ain't got nothing to say though
oh
Eerie jumps
so
yeah off Target your deployment to gray
didn't go quite as planned no matter
secure our Bossier faith and continue
those Heretics don't always come with
them very cute very cute
and they're all you're the only survival
oh I assumed they sent me down alone
oh My Friends Are Dead
this looks really cool I recognize that
I can go that way
all this way damage accumulating address
humans I'll be fine is this loop around
or is this a secret
I ain't no secret no oh yeah you look
around okay
definitely feels a lot like Doom yeah
which we like okay cool
Medicaid item
I hope that goes over
here press V
yeah it also works in your second mouse
click
oh that's they should have said that and
that's without
uh do I have to use the Medicaid no they
didn't Auto use it it's also okay
whoa that's a cool animation
it seems fun yeah I was wondering why it
froze me
hold on
straighten up
give me all secrets yeah that is just
the start uh press wait stop press t
are you talking to your home the snow
I hate snow
you're gonna get through all my lines so
did they just give you like a list of
150 things to yell four hours worth of
just yelling for four hours
was it fun it was amazing
four hours is a long time ago yeah I was
burning out
my uh voice started getting compromised
but luckily we were at the end
because you gotta have the same energy
it's not like you can play yeah like I
can't you can't all of a sudden then
it's all going to fit within the
aesthetic right yeah you're sort of
doing a voice as well
but not
forgive no one
I'm trying to be a oh give us
did you feel weird yelling this kind of
[__] because the Space Marines aren't
necessarily the good guys in my opinion
no one's the good guys yeah uh no like
if it feel weird no it's it's sort of
fellow Shakespeare oh yeah I can see
that it's yelling a bunch of propaganda
but in a Shakespearean way yeah
oh that's cool
you haven't do none of that let's eat
all right
and you could also spam that button
missing missing website Health like for
bigger enemies
stay on them
nope
like Dash basically
yeah I saw Jacob do this and fail at it
yeah
the like lighting is awesome it's pretty
and you can adjust how much pixels you
want oh can you yeah so if you go to
options then go to video
oh sorry display uh costs uh
there was maybe Retro Retro
uh I like the bloom yeah retro palette
whoa
pixelation well put that back to 100
yeah
oh my God that's so cool let's try that
dude
I'm sick
yeah it's kind of difficult
go back to like
default just hit reset oh yeah
there it is
so epic
this is a really episode
the bolt gun it's really pretty too man
I love the way this looks and yes it one
thousand percent
feels like Doom maybe a little bit
slower which probably makes sense
because you I'm pretty pretty big boy
well I feel like the Doom Sprint feels a
little faster maybe not
oh they got Purity seals
nice nice nice
yeah they've nailed the uh this is sick
yesterday
oh that's where I came from isn't it oh
no
wait don't you why not
just jump
but I want shooter you wear a ton
oh it's interesting how much spray they
have it's well
storage
yeah sound design is good too
I don't need it I guess
I'm helped up
I like this little akuaku you've got oh
crew up yeah servos
I only understand things if you give me
to them give them to me and crash
manicure times
all right
it's so like formal it's cute
this [__] the sound of how heavy he
Stomps to that's it
I feel like an astronaut yeah
exit locators leave within
I can't find this one damn secret
no well I would actually guess it was at
the start
when we
oh really
batteries it Trails where the mountains
there's an adaptations
planetary defense batteries align the
root
as do Heretics finally into the ham Zone
Purge any resistance
foreign
yeah and the fact that there's like this
little screen Shake as he Stomps
it's really cool
you're a heavy boy
there's actually a guy you could kill
but you don't get anything for that
what do you mean oh is somebody coming
here if you look around
it's around this corner
absolutely
you know you can burst through them with
Dash
really that's F isn't it yeah
oh
this is definitely like more brutal than
do not more brutal than brutal dude no
not more brutal than brutal dude but
like more brutal than bass Doom in it
like which which is good you should feel
super badass as a
uh uh Space Marine
welcome Brothers
oh God
all right go jump yeah
oh you son of a bishop oh he can climb
yeah
down down down down down down
sorry about that mate
I don't know how you missed all the
barrels
oh I mean it was intentional
I guess they explode yeah
what was that oh frag grenades I didn't
realize that
it's cute to change uh
it is
um G boom that's cool
hello big boy
I wonder if that's the
final boss or something no the Titan
films the first baseman yeah
uh okay
absolutely dunked online absolutely
ruined
no
oh
yeah this is uh very cool in oh this is
where I came from yeah yeah
um and then it feels like it's
no must be
um it feels like Doom but it literally
does feel like a modern version without
like losing
the identity you know
yeah it like
what's modern about it
um the dash the fact that I can climb
I mean the tone button
who are you talking to mate him
the fact that you can like rev up the
chainsaw
yeah it's a nice way of modernizing it
without making it feel um
uh identical
oh without making it feel too different
in this way the Warhammer communities
were saying they've been asking for a
game like this like
since the 90s
yeah what's the game that sort of looks
uh like obviously Gears of more copied
off of Warhammer but the one that looks
Gears of worry
oh it's Facebook that's your Space
Marine too well it's the first place
the one that this is the one we got the
new trailer for yeah so the Space Marine
I think was 2010
on the 360.
um and PC you can pick it up on Steam by
the way right now I really like Raul
does not work there I do now well not
really no
no presenting skulls that's true you're
Affiliated this will come out before
scars
you're right it will yeah skulls 25th
what
it's the most dramatic role yet
a bit more dramatic okay music I was
gonna say the only thing I'm not loving
is I wish there was a little more
do you mean music yeah
kicked in here
oh
hello my eggs
and if you chainsawed him
Revit and it was like cut through him
they also shoot
a fair bit less predictably than the
enemies in Doom 2. oh sorry Doom do
because they're they're faster and they
scatter more oh hang on
yeah that's walking tiny
go through that door this one yes I just
assumed out to come back here
accessible
they're just chatting
nice
it's nice how many grenades it gives you
I will say
um
I
this is obviously only the second level
but I actually might want to up the
difficulty
um
I feel like they ain't uh
ain't hurting me much on the
accessibility options uh you can click
on and then invincibility immediately oh
that's awesome I love one games yeah
um
I'm just basically unlock the whole
thing
that's it chapter select is like one of
the best things ever it's nuts that
people don't do chapter's lives
me being big and Stumpy
nice throw it's very easy to throw feels
good
yeah absolutely yeah it sort of goes
where you kind of hope it yeah it's
really accurate
exploded I don't think it did either
changes
and having a button to rev it also feels
really cool
I'm all right with doing it because they
are everywhere
I think they did
you know
okay well what does that do
I'm wasting it something I've only got
28 seconds to use
I think you just boxed
he exploded
that's why I want to do it because I'm
like oh that looks like it's a punch so
it probably gives me the ability to
to punch good you know what I mean
missed a couple of years
thank you
scanning meat status tainted
it's not me
oh hello mate
the secrets
oh
um okay don't tell anybody go away no
you're going the right way neither where
you were looking this video
you're like glowing yeah I noticed that
I think that was a secret I picked up
maybe
the glow looks really cool that's like
just dope pixel art
you actually used
super cool
nice
not one barrel took out
they were so close to it
big dummies sometimes me and my homies
just like to stand around explosives
so
so game is nowhere to go
I think there's a reason for that though
what was like a Canon reason yeah
yeah was it Faye
no tickets okay
yeah I'm just gonna clear one out fast
not sure
who's that
it's heavy
he's Evie
you're dead yeah
we gotta get that somehow
oh mate
ah I overshot it
which I couldn't pick up anyway
apparently
it's just a more medic whatever
Medicare
nice respawn uh vicinity
speedy
didn't come back alive
that's why
these guys
what the Frameworks oh yeah sure
damn some health on them yeah
they have a place
you can kind of snipe
so powerful
yeah that's super satisfying
just yet
foreign
looked flammable so can I get up there
but maybe not
how often do you press it when you play
me 10 seconds
is that gnosticism
it heightens it when you're doing like
the big like
um Purge battles where you're like
overwhelmed in a room kind of in the
family style I'll just slap it now and
again
thank you
I don't know maybe I'm biased I don't
you know I don't usually like any of my
work
very difficult
I think I'm in I've kind of
that's awesome
but I like how I sound I like to build
something um
[Music]
oh
yeah these big boys
I love that you knew the grenade
just enjoy that mate
I've purposely not finished this I just
I told you I I had it since yeah you
wanted to wait till it comes out right A
Clash for about it well I think uh the
Davis publishes it will be out today
yeah right yeah I would have had it run
straight back
so I had it for babies too
and I intentionally
I just wanted to savor it I mean we're
playing something in isolation as well
like yeah you can't share it or talk to
anyone about it and you're not seeing
other people play it you're gonna watch
people play through on YouTube and
twitch and stuff uh yeah probably I know
Lawrence is looking forward to it you
know he plays like boom on the freaking
old trick nightmare nightmare
um
you send hold the pen Cavill or coffee
yeah
made me give one to moist critical
examples
Charlie I sent one to Markiplier yeah
all the Obama I think we'll have a fans
right now well markings yeah so strong
I think Charlie said he's like trying to
it's new to him he's like enjoying it
you are still a good one too
open to Bruce
ah damn what the heck you [__] around
well I'm trying to find Secrets secret
Secrets oh
you can't pick up health and uh
over 200 yeah but you can you can pick
up but then what's the limit on those
things
who knows I think it won't let me
wait
okay where was it that I was just down
here I think that was a secret just the
fact that it looks like I can walk on it
made me curious enough to check
nah
it's worth having a look
bye
yeah I mean I lose some health but
there's so much of it laying around
but it's okay
yeah I'm sort of slidy so keep me like
oh I'm gonna fall off again which I
wonder if that's just a nice thing it
could be I think you just slide around
the ice
together
yes
[Music]
sector imperialis
streets are quiet too quiet the stench
of heresy abounds I love my favorite
thing about warmer
and I didn't get it until I like the
more I've dived into it it's just how
much we all talk about heresy goddamn
Heritage so funny to me looks like the
local Military Arms defenses didn't fare
too well descend through the Hub the hab
purify it as you go some secrets to
concealed behind seemingly normal walls
that totally was a secret
you should have pushed through walls
they've got Doom like invisible walls uh
so they're platforming I would bet money
you've done that I do that in whenever I
tab into like dark tide as well
what a game I love
it I don't care
you don't know you don't have to care
the streets are quiet it's actually this
level feels a lot like um vermontide oh
verminton really yeah
I mean doc tied as well I suppose
it's almost like they're the same
universe it's crazy
why everybody dead
you know what Warhammer around here okay
it weirdly reminds me of Judge Drex in
2018. yeah
it's a very British take for you to have
I like that our stuff's just right here
did I have something that you can tell
when you're watching an Australian
commercial versus an American one even
if they're muted
um pink Horrors
Oh you mean a pinky
I guess
um yeah
Australian commercials
people just look like people in American
commercials they all look like models oh
it's a really obvious difference
yeah but they've just got like Perfect
Teeth and perfect hair the Aussie ones
just looks like a dude it's like a guy
you know
so many ways to go here
Heretics how long is the game oh no idea
sick
I read somewhere
I think I read about Christine
solid
what's that
oh hello
oh
good stuff hey hydrogen as we go
wait I think you missed a blue hole
I was like I'm sure I saw them
unfortunately oh look up
mmm
looking good
I'm gonna have to stick around
maybe the Boost
boost jump
oh nice
did you boost yeah
I think it does send you further yeah
for sure
yeah level design solid like I know
where I am and where I'm going mm-hmm
it's definitely not like puzzly in the
way that Zoom sorry Doom is puzzly
I think it will get a little bit puzzly
interesting
Heritage I'm curious about the enemy
variety as well like are we gonna
see like Orcs And that
Orcs
you just have to do like a whole game
full of them on the Space Marine sure
you get different chaos Heretics another
sure
a doom doesn't have a huge amount
it's not that much it's not nothing but
it's no time where you going now whoa
what the heck
that's so cool
okay
that's awesome
and yeah those look spirally yeah
I really thought there'd be someone in
there because of the white sauce
this doesn't have a time limit on it I
think it has uh ammo in it
like it was two clips or something yeah
the sound design is so good
yeah
it makes sense
I got all three in one
that rules
I mean I might have it my achievements
might not be active yet
sometimes on it's on PC for a while
it's a blue key in it right
you probably should
I don't know
this staircase I thought it was like
hiding him from me it's just a ramp
it's like Duke Nukem
Jake
in the face
yeah this is something that I mean you
already know this about me like you can
put me in front of Doom and I would just
sit there and play it for hours on end
but not do anything else
um and I've been like that for forever
this is exactly it's scratching that
exactly you've been doing that on
YouTube yeah I just pick it up and I
just sit there for hours but I also play
them so it's super challenging when
should we talk about the home mod oh my
God my home
one of the coolest Doom mods I've ever
even heard of we've got over three of
them yeah it's brilliant
I I think I want to play it a link in
the description
look at you YouTube and your little
influencer that's what you got saying it
I do say Link in the description and I'm
really bad about forgetting to put the
link in the description because I think
like I often upload things
after recording them like a replay or
whatever
uh but I completely forget that I
haven't said that I'm terrible about
also I know I sound like a Salesman but
I'm not you work on it well yeah but
this was a label this was this was love
I did it purely out of love I don't know
that's how you uh became a part of this
project well you know how'd you get
involved you know how much [__] I turned
down
that is true he does turn down a lot of
[__]
so it's I'm not one of those like work
hungry people I hate working
every job yeah you need a really good
excuse to work
um I live I don't live to work I work to
live
but yeah um but like your definition of
live is play FIFA when was I see you
soon it's probably like two days ago no
I haven't put it in ages
I know
huge news that's what people tune into
this wall having gameplay
yeah uh this game's like 20 bucks
on all platforms yeah
you played it on I wonder how PS5 as
well haven't you it runs great on PS4
yeah there's some frame rate drops here
that's kind of time where oh it's been
happening every now and then I ain't
seen anything yeah
that's also true
brilliant
no he's done that
he might have been me I'm gonna
accidentally hit that
why are you such a SIM for the emperor
Rahul
because sexy I mean he's
I wanna I just whatever I see him
he yelling about The Golden Throne
's Ultramar
we're planning it I don't know
I've been reading them books
I'm currently reading mathiston
since I was like 13 or 14.
um if you hadn't have got me into
Warhammer and told me to paint space
what happened I wouldn't have been in
the game yeah Rahul was painting uh
Legion and I was like dude you should
pay we'll have him paint me a blood
Angel because they were always my
favorite faction I never got into what
happened again but I uh read the books
and still have
fun
you have a just uh yell your own name
it's his eye
Rahul Kohli
wouldn't you love to do a voiceover
session like this it's just fun you just
shout yeah it would be fun
the uh the one dabs did an article where
they said
just wasted me
yes I saw that wasted your talent yeah
because I mean you're not really acting
you're sort of it was tricky though I
remember you you telling me afterwards
that it was kind of hard because you had
to you just had to yell foreign
Nuance but you're shouting the whole
time yeah so there's not like
a lot of emotions for you to play with
just the one
everything's got to have a certain uh
aggression
well also trying to be Shakespearean
yeah while being Shakespearean wow
and also still like making sure that not
every single line sounds exactly the
same what were we watching the other day
where the the Space Marines were
American
I was playing dawn of War
I'm just so odd yeah
feel like there's a secret to someone
that's all I'm trying to say press e e
or whatever Pizza open doors
[__] pink horror
it's his eye
um
he says to them while they're dead
it was upon them it was
you're not wrong
what did you say how did they get into
the game
did you treat the Resident Evil dude
like this
um or did you ask him proper question
well we were doing a podcast about
acting and I know you streamed with it
oh we didn't talk I didn't I didn't ask
him [__]
we just played the game
um
uh Nick everybody you know it's kind of
must be some guests online uh
you guys the question was oh yeah sorry
I'm on a PCA
um uh ignau.com
uh how did you get involved with the
project that's weird
brilliant
can we get um more than More Than Just
Two Words sure yeah I went on Twitter on
a tweet
okay what did you tweet then so
basically in skulls Warhammer skull I
keep seeing you and being like who is
this man because you don't have a beard
yes everyone
I've lost my res R is gone I still have
a chin though so don't be [__] well
he was holding all the reason his uh
don't be calling me out
about my face structure um but
um
this was for different jobs
um uh so uh uh skulls I think June 1st
2022 the Warhammer skulls conference
yeah
they debuted the teaser trailer for
Bolton and
um
saw it and was and I just got into
Warhammer in January I think of 22 so
last January and my first like lead uh
chapter or whatever was faction was was
ultramarines
for ultramarine Ultra Marine uh so yeah
and I was called rahulture Marine
because of that artwork that Paul did
for me of me as an ultramarine that the
guy does the magic and Warhammer art
anyway uh so I just tweeted uh I know it
wasn't but this game was made for me it
been a massive Doom fan and now like an
ultramarine Warhammer Fanboy painter
painter who just started playing
tabletop too I hadn't oh at the time you
hadn't no well you haven't no no I have
now but I'm um
I need to spending time
you've gone pretty hardcore into
painting so it's not like you're yeah I
mean every shows and the games I'm like
yeah sure I've played a lot of games now
it's a cool thing about Warhammer is
there's so many avenues like I've not
played the game either but um I've I've
Loved reading a lot of books some of
them are pretty bad actually but
um
a lot of good video game variety as well
yeah I love dark time
yeah this is dark type as hell
oh
it's like Sarah Connor
um yeah uh so yes I just tweeted that
this game was made for me being being a
big Doom Fanboy that I was and then
apparently or they just saw the tweets
and I don't I'm not sure I I think I saw
in the interview they were like at some
point they were they wanted to hire an
actor or someone to do it but like
yeah it wasn't I don't know they they
wanted someone who would care
and then apparently the social media
team saw it and they're like yo roll
Cody [__] tweeted about it and then
like who the [__] that
um and then they picked one of Winston
credits
um yeah and then um I got a message
saying hey
uh can we get your emails of your reps
it's fun
um
wait wait wait wait wait wait what's in
the middle yeah it's another gun
get it
just taking care of the mess first here
they're gone oh that's all right I'll
take it with me
that's funny why are you standing next
to a chaos there's tons of them
oh
I see plasma yeah
but it hurts you does it yeah think a
bit like a grenade all your health slope
think of it as like a grenade launcher
or a rocket launcher like the I see
hold on
nice
um
yeah
that was it uh they sent me an email and
I thought it was to like play it early
and they were like would you like to do
a voice and then I thought because it's
two minutes like didn't God doesn't talk
yeah so I thought maybe it was like one
of his companions or a storyline and
they're like no
the standard kaido we go into the voice
and it's just taunts would you be
Wellington [__] yeah
um
and uh
it was
I told my team as well know that you
want to do stuff is a great way to get
to doing stuff you know my team are very
good at getting me the best deal
possible and they love to like that's
what they that's what they're there to
do they're like you want to work with
royal Coley here's how that would be a
million dollars I called my lawyers
well gun came through and I went don't
take the piss
don't don't [__] about they're a small
uh developer in Bristol like chill out
they say [__] fortnite yeah
yeah and we had a very
nice deal
prison life yeah you shouldn't take
penis
which upsets my manager all the time
and then I went in and I recorded it
when we were when I was filming the Hulu
show you remember
oh and I was pissed because the night
before we're recording this they had me
outside on a speedboat
wearing nothing but like a v-neck yeah
and like yelling no no no yeah we were
yelling next to each other and it was
sunset in Vancouver in October
and I can feel my throat going and I
wanted to be like to the job that my
main job that was paying me proper like
you know my real money uh I wanted to be
like hey can you guys uh wrap this up
because I've got I got bolt gun to do
tomorrow
yeah
the winter sore throat yeah you don't
want to go in with a job like that oh no
go
that's what um fans were calling like
covid
knuckle yeah that's cute
you and me are on the same level
oh you barely touched it mate yeah I
told you I was savoring it
was so much loot
is this gonna be a boss fight
this does feel like one of those do
maternal arenas
yeah
and it really is because you pick up
contempt that's what it's called the
shields
I just feel like Shrek's about to show
up
that's a very obscure that was a deep
cut my house yep
have you ever tried to make a doula no
um I used to play with level editors
like quite a bit when I was younger
because I really liked it in Halo yeah
um but it's been a while we should try
yeah
I wonder how hard it is
there's a key here somewhere I have some
awful trivia though murder trivia
to do what murder just a purpose of
nothing you know the Columbine shooters
Columbine yeah it's always driven me
nuts that you say Columbine what is it
Columbine what's the difference you're
saying Columbine
it's Columbine
irrelevant no that's not relevant to the
way the thing's pronounced why are they
stopping like that Columbine why are
they doing that Columbine
yeah Columbine
I don't understand I can't it's really
this is where I get like my brain
doesn't work on this like where is this
key Columbine Columbine that doesn't
make sense we're gonna get demonetized
for saying the phrase column line too
often it's still a real place isn't it
yeah oh then
which I'm not say it anymore no you can
so you know I did I did know Columbine
shoes yes they recreated the scoring
doom and would run it yeah
it's pretty horrific
I don't know what a band Doom
yeah they've been not the gun trying a
band Doom it was the map editor
out of it
man
is this this is not a segue that's
related this is just in general great
can't wait for whatever you're about to
say next man how can it get worse
Carmack
and Romero [__] me man
those are the original creators of Doom
everyone
read if you guys get a chance you're
looking for a really good I knew I
picked up the wrong key um because this
level's doing my puzzly you asked for a
puzzle
don't they never go
secret secrets
make sure you don't pick up a weapon
thing that you might need later
yeah for the year
um
yeah guys if you're looking for um uh a
good book uh I implore you to read
masters of Doom
so really good uh read which is based on
it's basically the telling of how it
software came to be and
power
we're big
very big fan I do think the uh Doom 93
is my favorite game right three yeah
yeah I was gonna ask you over two yeah
absolutely and you prefer 2016 to return
I do yeah
yeah they're different enough that I
feel like I don't have to choose they
are yeah and I I the thing about the
difference between demotonal and doom
2016 is that I get why they made every
change they did in fact they literally
did the thing that everyone like mocks
Developers for saying they're going to
do what they don't do this they listen
to the criticism which was it's really
just a series of hallways and rooms
which is true
um I just really liked that
so they changed up the level design and
added the uh
platforming um I just wasn't planning
platform that's the reason I don't like
a title is much but the level design is
better
right off the chest
it's so nuts how similar this feels to
dark type like obviously it should but
different developer it's a very
consistent tone just the way that like
even these holes are mapped out
like it feels like I'm playing a retro
version of doctor
I didn't go
I'm really having trouble navigating
here because everything does look really
similar
uh
oh yeah I keep forgetting
[__] Noble right really hard to kill
again I was gonna
we were both going to play this game and
talk about this game
oh yeah regardless if you're involved
yeah it was just like winning when you
got it it was awesome because we're
already really excited about that
um I think that this is I was really
happy with this game
um
I'm mad excited for the release I hope
yeah I would think anyone who likes Doom
is gonna have a good time here
I think there's room for it
that makes sense like
the first kind of proper Warhammer game
of the time
in the Retro shoes
which was 20 20. there have probably
been some indie member Shooters oh wait
hell what was the one troy did with the
music Hellsing a mental health singer
I had wipes I really like that game
yeah but can Troy Baker do this
absolutely not never heard him do that
once in my life
imagine that in Last of Us
you invoke my eye of Filth wow Joel
I'm gonna get out
no I think I have to go back oh we
actually got the key yeah
oh my God
I'm scared you're gonna lose your help
from you I actually think I've lost most
of my health for my own plasma yeah
that's the same thing I didn't realize
that I I was getting hit I didn't know
until you told me obviously I'm pretty
longhold right now but
same room this is where I came in though
isn't it
it is
what have you [__] done this way
maybe yeah
yeah that was good
I think I came through here before I was
still in the same [__] room
left
and I escaped yeah yeah what's that uh
it's the shotgun
oh boy
what's up behind you yeah you walk past
them
what's going on here
I'm going left yeah
it's just a lot of noise oh
I love hitting them when then they jump
nice that killed me I didn't have to put
I smoked too much
didn't have a long capacity for it I
remember that one
I'm not hearing the same lines that
often so that's good no really
unfortunately four hours a bit and it
only took a few seconds to do one
how many tapes did you do
three of each uh no we stopped doing
that I think we did two
uh once they were kind of happy with the
Reed
this didn't A and A B take an A and A B
and if they wanted a c then we would go
and pick it to do a super uh just
because it became uh a big like broken
string don't pick it up
why oh okay
because you're gonna need it remember
where it is
Begin The Purge
there's a bit unstuck on you saw me
I was trying not to watch you play so
that I didn't have anything um spoiled
me so I've actually watched very little
of you
I'm almost made it hard
I get nerves it's because I keep
thinking it's the shotgun
uh
and alas it is not it's back to the
d-pad on the PlayStation
oh yeah I guess because you don't have
that many weapons
no those are good few weapons
yeah
in this game yeah
I think you can see more than four of
the trailer okay
yeah all right I'm just using the
Scrolls
do you wish you were a blood Angel
instead
look I do love me some blood angels I'll
allow it
foreign
dirty dirty blade codes for sure
damn you got some reach on that tongue
that actually really helps thank you
the wives are good
love it
you need a second player is multiplayer
but they can only press the talk
ugh
uh knuckle I think so I just jump right
through
oh he's still alive
oh
God they're so strong yeah
bling-toed bullet sponges right Jay
banjo
hey
CBD oh
you know technically this isn't the
first space
well that's you could floss it as that
but that don't make it correct
it is armor looks the same it doesn't
make him a Space Marine be careful now
I think he almost finished the purge I
have finished the punch
they told me I did
exit located behind doorways is that
what you just said
uh the servo skull yeah so I guess
cool that this is this like Mission had
um
distinct difference from the others uh
oh well because yeah uh just very boss
fighty
okay what color key did you pick up
yellow I think okay
that's blue in the Left Right purple
mate
down the middle
that's where you pick the key out all
right I just picked it up from here yeah
maybe it's at the bottom oh that's it
yeah
I have a little chat one of them showed
me is sorry Lads really yeah that
it did didn't it yes 100 it did you're
gonna get demonetized show me his little
bottle
for free in this economy
ready to paint more
um
that would be fun
I could probably do a naval yeah
they both did the butthole
double butthole again for free in this
economy
um you know what's going on you can see
I'm back here again no you're not
oh okay
a lot more purging to do oh [__] you got
30 seconds
well you got this boost oh right yeah
I'm seeing a lot though
where everybody even at
what's happened to the sound is it the
secret
s
hairy mate
you're the bloodiest stars in this
it sounds like a shattering glass that's
sick
it's oh
stop using that
well they're so oh big boy
oh 25 health
go find it
gotta be hidden in one of the nuts
nooks and all crannies
help help help help help
because he [__] died
well
that's awesome
oh he's still alive
oh good timing good timing
that was rough
um we're gonna leave it there
as close as I am to finishing that
game's awesome super fun thanks for
joining me thanks game is out today
so we play the first hour
I'm clearly gonna finish this game
all right definitely
very very fun for Ultraman thank you for
watching I'll see you next time